Well, you know, everyone's headed back to the office,
and now the Washington Post reports that means it's time
to hop on the gossip train.
I love it.
Experts say gossip can actually bond people at work,
and now, hot gossip's back on.
People aren't just in it for the spicy stuff,
like who's getting flirty around the big printer,
even though I totally know who is.
There's also some real positive sides to gossip.
People can trade info, like how to handle a tough manager,
or who to ask for your next raise.
I'm sorry, but if you wanna gossip,
and I'm looking and I'm talking to you,
please, please, come do it with me.
(clapping) Please, it's my favorite thing to do.
Ross.
I love knowing everything.
I mean, you have an appetite
for gossip, right?
I do.
You guys wanna try something we've never done before
here on the show?
Like a first.
A first, we're gonna start a brand new segment
called "What's The Rossip?", hey!
Okay.
(audience applauding loudly)
So, these are some stories I'm obsessed with
I wanna talk with you all about.
Did you hear Britney Spears just sorta, kinda,
maybe announced that she's pregnant on Instagram?
Did you guys see that?
Yeah!
Well, now all the news sources
have been contacting her for confirmation.
I don't have that yet, okay? (laughs)
But I, I mean, if she's having a baby, this is, I mean,
she's having this, like, whole resurgence in her life,
it's such a beautiful time, and, ooh,
you know, she's having a baby one more time. (chuckles)
All right,
(audience laughing)
here's another piece of Rossip.
Simon Cowell, he's the face of AGT, America's Got Talent,
but now he says he might have Botoxed and fillered before,
but no more for him.
Really?
Yeah, he says he might've gone too far.
(chuckling) Oh, maybe.
(Drew laughing loudly)
I would never say that.
He would, though.
That's what I love about Simon Cowell.
Like, I used to
love him on American Idol.
Of course.
I just loved the way he just
was dead honest, and it sort of was,
you felt like it was mean-spirited,
but then there was also like a, oh, yeah,
somebody could address the elephant in the room.
Leave it to Simon.
Yep, leave it to Simon.
You want one more piece of hot Rossip?
Yeah!
You guys want it? Okay.
Well, this one's not really celebrity-based,
but if you have been following me on Instagram,
@helloross, thanks so much, you've seen,
there's this gray cat that comes into my new backyard,
and every day, I've been, like,
making friends with this cat,
and I named her Joy because she brings me joy.
Aww!
And I just found out
that Joy is a boy.
So, Joy Boy and I are friends,
(audience laughing)
and every day, Joy Boy comes over
and I give him little treats, and guess what?
I just got belly cuddles, alright?
So, that's breaking-hot Rossip.
(audience applauding)
I love it.
I have a boy's name.
You do!
Yep.
So, Joy Boy, bring it on.
All right, next up,
we've got some lunch ladies in Florida
who absolutely won April Fool's Day this year.
The New York Post reports, on April 1st,
they gave a pre-K student their lunch tray,
and that had a surprise Easter egg on top.
Now, the colorful eggs look like they might be, you know,
ready to hatch some candy,
but then when the kids opened them up,
they found vegetables.
Oh!
Sides of broccoli, to be exact.
Punked by the lunch ladies!
Oh, I love 'em.
I had a lunch lady who was so nice in high school.
Her name was Judy, and she would give me extra tater tot.
So, hi, Judy, hi!
I love tater tots!
The most underrated potato product, I know.
That's what I wanna do when I find an Easter egg,
and I love my vegetables, but even I was like,
oh, I would want something different than broccoli too.
I might've been with the students on this one.
You know, if I ever got you an Easter basket,
I would put little eggs in, and I know what I would put
in the eggs for you.
Can I guess?
Well, you don't have to guess
'cause look what I have for you right here.
Here is a little basket.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(clears throat) And I wonder if you know
what's gonna be inside your little plastic egg.
Is it macaroni and cheese?
Why don't you open the egg and look?
(audience laughing)
(Drew screams excitedly)
(Drew laughing loudly)
(audience applauding)
There's a fork in here.
(Drew screams excitedly)
Oh, Rossie!
I love you.
I love you so much!
This is exactly what I need today.
I know her.
Oh, my God!
Rossie, you see me, you know me!
I do know you, I do.
(upbeat music)